de la musique électro basé sur des
basses profondes et puissantes
les amateurs de dub step à des
rendez-vous le 7 décembre au vélodrome
nationale pour la soirée ambassades
l'occasion de fêter les 10 ans du label
never say die le plus grand des labels
dubstep
en ce moment on y trouve absolument tous
les artistes du moment et aussi toutes
les grosses têtes d'affiché de la baisse
physique aujourd'hui enfin
particulièrement d'absents passer par
des mercenaires
[Musique]
ces violences et ces bonne ambiance les
gens qui viennent sont courts il ya du
bon sommeil et le système sont est quand
même assez sent pas bon ont mis pas mal
de glace de 21h à 6h du matin une
dizaine d'artistes se sont succédé sur
scène son boy space l'ices ou encore up
prophète en raison des mouvements
sociaux certains budgets n'ont pas pu
être présents ce qui n'a pas semblé
gâcher le plaisir des participants
c'est dommage mais ça vaut le coup ça
vaut le coup d'être là tout le monde est
sympa assez content de voir notre avis
bouda qui l'a justement donc très
content de le voir pour la première fois
sur toile ambassades six mois de
préparation c'était nécessaire pour
mettre en place cette soirée au
vélodrome nationale ambitions du site
devenir un nouveau pôle de référence
pour les artistes
rome est une structure très important de
très conséquente
du coup les artistes plus reconnu et
connu viendront encore et toujours y
sont l'événement a rassemblé de 1600
personnes